ne pas se fier aux apparences sur ses
cartes lancé à vive allure non pas des
habitués du circuit mais des prêtres
venus de toute la france
l'enjeu remporté en binôme la sixième
édition de la padre cup sa petite pique
comme rencontre pour nous on se
retrouvent pour prier pour faire des
retraites pour de la formation
là le terrain et c'est moins qu'on
puisse dire est un peu original hors de
la piste
on est vraiment dans le partage extra et
qu'on est sur notre carte à six sur la
non pas qu'on sait pas de cadeau mais on
à fond ou d'accélérateur virage à
l'accord du par l'extérieur dépassement
par la droite
chacun des 19 équipages en noir et col
romain peaufine sa stratégie
petite appréhension parce que c'est pas
mon sport favori je préfère le tennis
entre nous ce 10 mai mais j'aime bien ce
côté effectivement un peu de détente
entre prêtres un petit peu défi aussi
quand même parce qu'on cherche pas être
dernier forcément pour le plaisir
il ya un trophée mais ça je sais qu'il
ya des quasiment des professionnels
parmi mes confrères donc ça cesse et
mort à l'avant
et parmi les professionnels dont il
parle ce prêtre en compétition avec son
propre bolide
oh ça fait peut-être une quinzaine
d'années que un paroissien de mon
ancienne paroisse mais initiée aux
cartes
et puis finalement m'a donné un kart et
donc à partir de là je me suis mis à à
pratiquer sa régulièrement
après quelques tours arrêt au stand
obligatoire pour passer le volant aux
coéquipiers
le bitume du circuit beltoise de trappes
ainsi chauffé pendant cette course
effrénée d'une heure c'est le binôme du
père pierre amar du génie qui s'imposait
devant celui du pilote averti père
françois lainée de paris